[Music]
on today's show we're going to be
talking about being in relationships
with people
who are struggling with mental health
issues talking about brothers and
sisters
spouses friends we're going to be
talking about
living into the winter seasons we know
we've been inside and it may get worse
so what are some things we can do right
now to take care of our hearts
our minds and our mental health as we
head into the winter months stay tuned
what's up i'm john and this is the dr
john deloney show
taking calls about your life from you
by you and about you talking about
relationships your relational iq
mental health parenting your marriages
we're gonna be talking about people who
wear
vintage band t-shirts to bands not only
they haven't seen live
but they don't even know who the band is
they don't know songs
they don't know lyrics and here's the
thing when i see somebody in a band
t-shirt
i instantly think same team or i don't
like you it's a good way for me to
divide the world up
instantly and now they're selling these
vintage
t-shirts to folks who don't even know
who these bands are
and i am making false generalizations
that usually help me get through my day
right so here's the thing if we live in
a country where people get carded for
cigarettes
they should have to pass an online quiz
in order to buy a vintage band t-shirt
they should be able to name a few songs
or a favorite lyric or something
i just need to know if i see you in the
yard
or in the mall or in a neighborhood or
whatever
if you're on my team or not right so
we're talking about anything and
everything including people who buy
vintage band t-shirts of bands they've
never even listened to
all of it right so whatever's going on
in your heart in your mind in your
universe i'm here to walk with you
let's do this give me a call at one
eight four four
six three that's 1-844-693-3291
don't forget you can email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com
and before we get going one quick note
crossfitters
i hear ya i hear ya
on the very first show i got a meme as i
was walking in here that was a
ridiculous
crossfit meme here's the thing i love
you crossfitters i love your sense of
community
i love your sense of support for one
another i really love the hard workouts
i'm a huge fan
and i love how you make up terrible
workout form
in the name of crushing reps right and
you give up
long-term inner like long-term injuries
who cares because right now
we got another pr right so i'm a huge
fan of crossfit i'm a huge fan
of the lunacy of it all and the
camaraderie
um so here's the deal i just think memes
are ridiculous
most of them are ridiculous if you are a
crossfitter
and you got your feelings hurt you
probably should go see somebody
you probably should find someone that
you can socially distance hug
and you should probably go crush a murph
and know that i fully support crossfit i
love you guys
um and i want you all to do good all
right so
same team same team let's go straight to
the phones let's go to brooke
in athens georgia brooke good morning
how can i help
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call thank you so much for calling
what's going on
um i would really love some advice about
how to
love my younger sister well she
struggles with
anxiety and i 100 know that it's real
but sometimes i feel like she uses it as
a crutch
okay give me an example walk me through
it so
um just a couple of examples um she's
turned down
promotions at work because she
thinks that the perceived stress will
give her too much anxiety
she's never worked full time because
she's scared if she works a full load
then
her anxiety will take over um
certain conversations or off or off
limits
just because it raises her anxiety
things like that give me an example of a
conversation that's off limits that
we're not allowed to have
so most of the time almost all the time
they're
about the future she really does not
like to discuss
the future in any way shape or form like
career goals
um marriage like what any kind of future
life she might have it just really seems
like
all future topics are off limits and so
how does this impact
you so i
love my sister so much and i really want
to be someone that can be vulnerable
with her
and that she can come and be vulnerable
with and
i just feel myself really just being
frustrated
and not being as
open with her or not being as receptive
as i could be to her
issues because i just feel like all of
the things that we should be talking
about
are are not allowed to talk about gotcha
so this sounds like you're the one with
the challenge not your sister because
when i hear what you've talked about
your sister
it sounds like somebody who's got some
anxiety issues who has drawn
right wrong or indifferent her own
boundaries for how she can best navigate
a day
and if she's not coming to you
for money or not coming to you like hey
i can only work three hours a week
because i've got anxiety and i need you
to pay all my bills and let me move in
and i need my kids to move in with you
right something like that that would be
like affirmatively impacting you
proactively coming after you
it sounds like you're just frustrated
that you have this picture of
this relationship with your sister that
you're not able to have because of the
boundaries she's drawn
is that fair i yeah definitely i
definitely think that could be true and
i know that
i i'm 100 okay with working on myself
sure but i just don't know how yeah so
i think at some point you've got to
grieve the fact that
she's living a different picture than
the one you want her to be in
um i i live firmly under the the belief
that
um having anxiety having adhd having
depression all these things are context
but they're not excuses
and so what i mean by that is it frames
things up
um but it doesn't mean i can't go to
work it doesn't mean i can't
i don't need to work really hard so that
i can be a functioning
contributor to my community to my
relationships
to the people around me but i don't have
to live into somebody else's expectation
of me
if i choose to only work part-time or if
i choose
the one thing that you told me that i
was off the cuff was proud of your
sister
is she's going to get promoted into a
position that she knows
that's going to be a lot for me to
handle and i don't think that's a good
idea for me to take that position
for somebody who struggles with anxiety
that's that can be a really
wise move that can be somebody who has
made peace with themselves and know
if i've gotta you know take over 10
employees or if i've got to deal with
massive budgets i'm not going to sleep
that's not going to be good for me so i
know that this is where i'm
i'm going to cap out unless i want to do
some really hard work and
and start the healing process and if she
doesn't want to she doesn't want to
what you need to do is have a hard
conversation with yourself about what
you're missing from your sister what you
wish that relationship was like
maybe sit down and have that
conversation with her but at the end of
the day
she's drawing boundaries and you've got
to respect those
gotcha when you hear that tell me what
goes through your heart and
mind um i
well i'm definitely willing to do that
because
i feel like i definitely feel like
i tend to be more of a bossy older
sister role
that's not who i want to be there you go
definitely
and that's what i'm struggling with is
because of course
i want to be someone who's there for her
and not judge her
and i i need to make some moves within
myself to
to help with that but it's just sad to
see like so much
potential so much that she can
accomplish
so many things that you know i know
that's within her
and her just put so many stops
and hard stops in her life where she
won't move move past
where do you think her anxiety alarms
come from where do they originate from
do they originate from your
your home life did she have some trauma
or tragedy or
is like is she just a
wimpy person in your eyes like where do
you think they come from
um i there's not any trauma we
live super happy childhoods she
still lives at home um so does my other
sibling
um and they my one of my siblings is in
college but she's graduated
um and so i feel sometimes like
my parents have created that hammock
atmosphere instead of a safety net
atmosphere
and so i think some of my struggles come
from that just watching their dynamic
and seeing that some of her choices are
perceived by me to be
more so is she is she a younger sister
she is how is she the youngest no sir
she's the middle
middle okay and how old is she she's 25
25 still lives at home yes sir okay
yeah i think at the end of the day right
wrong or indifferent
um wasting time on resentment or judging
her motives that's only weighing you
down
and i know that's hard when people that
we love and that we care about
aren't becoming their full selves
or our picture of what their full self
is um
it's frustrating when our parents let 25
year old kids live at home
and don't force them out of the nest um
all those things are frustrating it's
really frustrating when you have a
sister that you want to disclose things
to talk about
sad things or good things or future
things with and they won't have that
conversation with you
and that is for sure for sure for sure
brooke it's for sure worth grieving
you need to be sad about that that sucks
like that's what sisters are for
is to share in the future and to
commiserate the past and to plan
together and
grieve together that stinks you know
what i mean and i don't think it's out
of bounds in fact i think it would be
wise for you to have a good
hard conversation with your sister about
the things that you're sad that y'all
are missing together
and that you hope that one day she will
consider doing the hard work to get
behind those alarms that are going off
and figure out why she's anxious why
she's unable to
work fully why she's unable to be out on
her own but more importantly
why she's unable to fully plug in and be
the sister that you would love her to be
and at the end of the day that's the
best you can do with that conversation
and you need to find a friend or two or
a boyfriend or girlfriend or husband or
or whoever you need to get together with
and sit down and just grieve this just
be sad
and then make a plan for moving forward
because you still need people to talk
about the future with you still need
people to
love on and you still need people to
you know grieve with on normal everyday
life things but
um at the end of the day that's your
sister's living her life and she seems
to create some boundaries for herself
whether they're good ones or not good
ones that's not for me to say that's not
probably for you to say even
um i i just hit send we just hit send
here
on a quick read on anxiety
it's a it's called redefining anxiety
it's a it's a book i wrote that's very
short
but it is a a reframing of what anxiety
is what it's not and some key ways that
if you actually are in the business of
wanting to get healed
if you want to change the way your body
responds to certain things
that you can get this book and start a
healing process and it's designed to be
quick it's designed to not
be over dramatic and not overly
scientific or nerdy
but it's going to be coming out in the
next month or two and so i would
recommend grabbing a copy of that giving
it to your sister tell her you're both
going to read it together when it's
available
and that may be a good place to start
but um thanks so much for the call i'm
heartbroken for you
because i know what how what a blessing
it is for me to have a sister i can talk
to and a brother i can talk to
and but i also know there's been seasons
when we didn't talk well to one another
and that's frustrating and heartbreaking
too and so
um be honest with her and then man
you've got to take care of you at the
end of the day
let's go to the next call let's go to
rachel in blackfoot idaho rachel good
morning how
we doing good morning i'm all right how
are you
outstanding outstanding how can i help
this morning
um i just have a friendship i want to
move on from but i'm worried about her
mental health and i don't know how to
like do that oh that's a good one man i
get this question
all over the country so walk me through
your relationship
um well we actually met because her
husband was cheating on her and i found
out and let her know like that's how we
became friends
oh wow welcome to it right yeah
that i mean that kind of write off gave
us like a deeper
connection just because i knew something
about her that people didn't know and so
she started coming to me with other
stuff she's divorced since then
and is now dating but i've just noticed
a lot of behaviors that like i can't
support
and she doesn't like if i tell her
or call her out on it she either ignores
it
or like once she threatened suicide when
i called her out on something
and i just feel like it's not a
relationship that i want to continue
because it's
bringing me down and not making me feel
good like i just have a really hard time
helping someone who doesn't want help
and i feel like she's
i don't know in all her relationships
she uses and uses
and uses and doesn't give anything back
and then i don't know
it's just a hard relationship so what
what
what joy do you get out of this this
relationship
well i care about her since i know her
and i that's about
all of it i don't know there's really
any joy i just feel almost
obligated because i care about her and i
worry about her
and i know she doesn't really have
anyone else to confide in
and so i i don't know i feel guilty
leaving it but i don't feel like there's
any joy there
is there a part of you that likes being
the hero or liked it until it got to be
a lot
um i that's kind of what i do in general
yeah with all my relationships i like
helping people and
i have a hard time walking away when
it's not serving me
i just keep helping and helping until it
breaks me
gotcha so number one i would
strongly consider you find somebody in
your life that you can be honest with
and vulnerable about that tendency
um my guess is you're somebody who's
attracted these type of folks forever
and if you're a safe place and you're
somebody that
um knows things or has some past
experiences that you can share that
makes you a safe place but it also makes
you
a magnet and another way of thinking
about it makes you a target
for folks who are soul suckers
right that yeah they just live to absorb
other people almost like a dementor
and but at the same time there's a
benefit to you
especially at the beginning right um it
feels good
it feels good to be wanted and be the
smart guy and a smart gal and be the one
who knows things other people don't know
that feels awesome
and man you're gonna end up in the same
situation where your friends become your
albatross and just
you're always treading water and it's
exhausting right
yeah um so here's my rule of thumb for
folks like this
number one if anybody in my sphere ever
whether it's my longest oldest friends
in the world
and i still am in close contact with the
guys that we all grew up on the same
street like when we were zero together
um if anybody in my sphere threatens
suicide i call them the calvary i don't
screw around with that i don't mess
around with that
and i also am real clear about with my
friends and community
after that happens once or twice then
i'm not your go-to person for that 9-1-1
is your go-to person with that do not
call me with that again
does that make sense because you they
are choosing
i've got to set my boundaries and
somebody else is continuing to jump my
boundary
with something on fire and throw it at
me and
i've said i don't want that in my world
okay and you have permission to do that
um the second one is if somebody
weaponizes suicide
that can drain everybody around you and
so again
that's for professionals to deal with
not for you
right and so pass that along i also
think it's fair to sit down and have a
hard conversation about your boundaries
and for somebody who does like it when
people reach out to them they do
like being the go-to person that's going
to be a hard conversation for you to
have
but the boundaries of i love you if you
are struggling with x y and z
i can't provide you support and
assistance for that so i want you to
call a professional
i won't be a good resource for you there
because i don't know what to do and
that's
weighing me down that's bringing a lot
on me and i'm unequipped to handle it
if you said words like that and really
draw firm boundaries
and then you followed it up with but i
do like hanging out with you if you're
fun and you're exciting and or you're
just regular sad right
awesome but if you just want to use me
as a trash bin
i'm not going to be a good person for
you and so how
how would how would you go about having
a hard conversation like that my guess
is you've never done that before
um i've done similar stuff before i've
oh yeah
good for you yeah tell me about it so
like i try to do that but
um yeah i don't know how i would do that
with her because i feel like it would
just
turn into her sobbing and telling me how
much she needs me and how much i've
meant to her and that
she can't believe that i'm doing this to
her and i i just feel like it'd be used
against me
and it might be and so the way i would
ask you to reframe it is
not something you're doing to somebody
but something you're doing for yourself
okay and if she is truly mentally ill if
she is truly struggling with
self-harm with suicidal ideation if she
is truly struggling with
some of these heavier things you're not
equipped to handle it
and by dragging it out you put yourself
in a position to actually hurt somebody
by continuing to accept and continuing
to accept and so
often one of the greatest things we can
do for people who don't know how to have
relationships they don't know how to
to lean up against boundaries
appropriately they don't know how to be
socially aware
is to teach them what a true boundary
looks like
and what true love with boundaries looks
like
and then they're adults and they can
choose to accept those boundaries or not
accept those boundaries that's their
decision not yours
um but at the end of the day making sure
that people are safe is priority number
one
if you've got a friend who says going to
hurt themself call somebody
call somebody call 9-1-1 if you don't
have a hotline number handy
we'll put a hotline number down in this
show's show notes um
we've done a couple of shows where we
put hotline numbers in there make sure
you have
a number where you can call if you've
got people like that in your life but
also
um draw firm boundaries i remember a few
years ago
i was speaking to a parent at one of the
universities that i worked at
and i let them know you can tell your
kid you cannot talk to me like that
you can tell your child you can't your
adult child you can tell
your adult friends do not call me
at 2 am when you're intoxicated and
dump the following on me we will have
those conversations in person we'll have
those conversations around
coffee or you will have those
conversations with a professional
i'm not that person i'm not equipped for
it
it would be the same as me inviting
friends over to do like
crazy workout programs and i'm not in
shape or they're not in shape
that's not being a good friend that's
just me trying to show off or
dump stuff on them or make them feel
less than or whatever
but people aren't there to be used
they're not tools people
are relationships right they're people
to be with and so
anyway i can belabor on this all day i
get this question all the time
the key is to look in the mirror and
draw your boundaries and establish them
and like i first started talking with
with with rachel here
um most people who find themselves in
this situation
actually liked it at the beginning they
liked being the go-to they liked being
the connected person the
oh yeah learning hard things and then
they realized very quickly
carrying that weight around is is
exhausting and
people like that tend to absorb you they
they look for that energy and they just
just again dementor is the only thing i
can think of but
uh and here's the thing we are heading
into a season
um where this is going to happen more
and more
it's going to happen more and more so i
want to back out
30 seconds 30 000 feet here and
remind everybody before covet hit
we were all totally fried stressed
burned out we were already out of gas
and we were able to
um you know compress our sadness we were
able to
hide our frustration and exhaustion
through busy and busy and busy
and buying things and running and
scrolling through things
we were able to just kind of shove it
aside we were able to
wallpaper over the cracks and our
marriages and in our friendships
with busyness and kids soccer games and
another dance recital another thing
another thing
and then covet hit and we all had to go
home and we all had to stare at each
other
and stare at each other and then some of
us across the country are still having
to just stare at each other
but before covid we were seeing a
massive increase across the country in
what researchers are calling diseases of
despair
and diseases of despair are suicide
organ disease failures like um liver
disease
heart disease those are diet related
those
are often depression related um and
an increase in addiction and so the
average life span
in the u.s had actually gone down the
last few years before
covet hit and these were all diseases
of compression diseases of despair
to nerd out a little bit if you take a
normal bell curve
some have even taken to calling this
long tail suicide
which means people aren't acutely
killing themselves
they're not using a gun or pills or
something like that jumping off a bridge
but they are coming home from work they
are
overweight they are grabbing poison out
of their pantry
or poison out of their fridge or they're
driving through and grabbing some poison
they are sitting on the couch and
drinking and numbing and
eating and lonelying themselves
to death it's a cultural
country-wide crisis and it's not even
cult it's not even our country it is
turning into a global thing we are just
so spun out and so exhausted
and good folks this was before covet
right
and so i was checking out the data
recently on
the coveted related mental health issues
and there is just
expert after expert after expert
predicting what they're calling
a far worse mental health pandemic
that's going to last for years and years
beyond covid
major increases in hotline calls
major increases in telehealth referrals
and calls
during covid some of that is great i'm
glad people are using these resources
but it's
it's again anxiety alarms they let us
know when we're disconnected
when we are in situations where we don't
have control
or our lack of predictability and
or when we are scared when we are
fearful and that's what covett has done
to us man
so here's what i want people to be weary
of i want them to
get on their guard a little bit i want
to exhale
start making plans again because here
we're coming into winter
and the we we have
had outside adventures we could just go
for walks we've had sunshine we've had
outside events we've started figuring
out ways to do outside kid things right
we were able to walk our dogs and all
that we're getting into winter
when it is cold and it is dark and our
tendency naturally is just to stay
inside
and we are going to have to be so
intentional
so intentional about living lives that
don't
compound this already growing anxiety
this already
growing depression that's already
growing inner
this inner dysthymia oh by the way we
have an election coming
luckily it's not a contentious election
and everyone's on the same page so
that's cool
good good grief so i want to read you a
couple things
a cd receive report revealed that as of
late june
about 25 of adults in the u.s had
reported symptoms
of an anxiety disorder that is triple
the rate of 2019 and my guess is that
many people are experiencing this
beyond that they just don't have the
words for it they don't have time
because they're too busy working that
third job trying to make ends meet
one in four young adults age 18 to 24
has seriously considered suicide in the
past month
that absolutely breaks my heart i've
been to too many funerals
i've been to too many ugly situations
and
dark homes and i've hugged too many moms
and dads
one of the unspoken burdens is on unpaid
caregivers
and workers who are taking care of
adult kids with special needs who are
taking care of
aging parents who are taking care of of
aging spouses
who are taking care of little kids folks
who aren't getting paid for this this is
just there every single day
in six months seven months of this
with no end in sight it just begins to
take a toll
on your soul right and so here's the
thing
um we're gonna have to be highly
intentional here's five things
five's a lot but five things that you
can do
start right now as we are heading into
october
as we are in early october start now
getting routines getting plans together
getting people together in your life so
you can get on top of this before it
just wipes us out come february
so number one no matter what get outside
make it a regular practice to get
outside if it's cold
bundle up if you are freezing
figure out a way to do it buy warm
clothes get yourself a toboggan get used
to the cold your body will
adjust find places to hike by the way
hiking
is just fitness nerds speak for going
for a walk um you gotta hike
walk play go outside during your work
day
people have been going outside to smoke
for years just go outside and take a 15
minute lap around your building it's
healthier for you than smoking
but make sure you get outside outside
number two
however you can wherever you can be with
people in person buy a heater
better yet buy some blankets they aren't
for decoration on your couch anymore
they're actually for keeping you warm
if you have to be outside with people be
outside get underneath them and
figure out how you can be in community
with other people
i don't care if you don't like them i
don't care if you think they're weird
spending time with other people is
critical over the next five to six
months
if you are isolated or alone and you
can't get outside you can't with other
people
facetime regularly make it a point to
call somebody
every single day in march of last year
when this kicked off i was real good
about it and i've actually fallen off
and so it's become one of my regular
practices to get on the phone and call
people
every single day i've even taken the
leaving hilarious messages on their
phone
i just call them and act like an idiot
on the phone it's important
number three do online counseling if you
need to if you need a professional
everyone's throwing their practice up
online go find somebody
number four get an eating plan and an
exercise plan even if it's in your
living room
my wife and i moved our gym into our
living room for a season before we moved
to our new place
that's got a garage because no one was
coming over and we both know the
connections between mental health and
physical health
so we just moved our furniture out of
the way and we put our weights and stuff
in the living room
and it worked out great for us it wasn't
pretty it wasn't nice it made the house
smell a little bit i don't care it was
important
eating plan eating plan eat real food as
much as possible
if you're interested on how i eat and
what my thoughts are nutrition and
mental health
i can do a whole segment on this stuff
i've been researching this stuff for
years
if you're on your own get it but take
care of your eating plan
and then the number five is start
creating
start creating there's something about
the creative process
that is therapeutic and heals us from
the inside out that can be riding
building gardening go hunting and
fishing dig a hole
move rocks one of the things we've done
for our young son who's got a lot of
energy
in a small house is we give him one hard
job a day
he gets one hard job a day it could be
weeds
it could be moving rocks around it could
be mowing it could be whatever the thing
is
it could be moving books around the
living room but i've seen his shoulders
stand up a little bit taller he's
finding some esteem that he may have
been missing he is
solving problems and it is helping all
of us around the house so
find ways that you can create find ways
that you can move so again
i'm very concerned about this oncoming
winter shutdown which is just a natural
depressing of
everybody's mood that happens every
winter it's just part of the season
it's going to be especially hard this
year so let's start planning
now let's start planning now to get
ahead of this all right let's go to
christopher in dallas
christopher in dallas brother what is up
how can i help you this morning
uh good morning mr delaney essentially
what i'm calling for is to find out
if there's any hope for my marriage or
if i just need to
to cut it off and go the way of the
great d unfortunately
my wife's got bipolar okay and she
didn't really have any issues before we
got together but for the past three
years
she's had manic episodes which results
in one accusations against me
for domestic abuse sexual abuse or
something along those lines
two um the kids getting placed with cps
and removed from the home
and then her hospitalization anywhere
from two to three weeks to
three to four months depending on how
bad her episode is
and really i've tried everything that i
can think of we've gone to counseling
six different times and got her set up
with a fitness
trainer you know done everything i can
think of my family's
you know you need a divorcer now my
church is you must never divorce under
any circumstances and really i just i
don't know what to do
man can i just sit with you for a second
and tell you that sucks and i'm sorry
that's happening to you
yeah i hate that for you man um
bipolar is one of the most over
diagnosed
mental health diagnostics in in the
country um but when it is real
it can be devastating for entire family
systems man and i'm sorry
you said you got little kids tell me
about them
um gavin is three
wonderful we call him helper and uh so
of course he loves to help everybody and
everything he does things around the
house he loves picking up and playing
with
helping his sister and then um our
daughter her name is eliza rose we call
her keeper
um running joke there is you know we saw
her we wanted to keep her
sure she's about nine months old um
and in the past three years they've
lived with us for
a couple of for about a year they've
lived with both sets of grandparents and
even the great grandparents
culminating for about half of gavin's
life who's three
why were they taken out of the home
well because every time there's every
time there's accusations for domestic
abuse or sexual abuse or anything like
that cps has to error on the side of
caution and remove
the children from what could potentially
be a dangerous environment
to figure out what's going on um the
first couple of times it took
longer for me to get them back because
they had to really really do an
investigation
but it seems to be taking less and less
time as this becomes more and more
frequent
sure um
and there was no validity to the
accusations or anything like that they
were just baseless what set her off
well so it's a different thing every
time um it's not
it's it's something supposedly something
traumatic which
i don't always consider traumatic but
she does and that seems to be the
important part so the first one
was um giving birth to her son
gavin the second one was us moving from
utah to texas
the third one was her niece was born and
lived for a couple weeks and died
um the fourth one was covet and then the
fifth one
was our son got moved from publix or
from private school
to public school because he just wasn't
ready and that was the last one to set
her off
um last friday and so when you say set
her off
paint me and the listeners a picture of
what a
set off mother looks like who's
struggling with bipolar
well so it starts it's for her it's very
specific
for her it starts with the anxiety from
the events
whatever that event is then it goes to
lack of sleep either she's going out and
trying to cool off and having a couple
of drinks
um so she comes home 2am gets up at 5am
just doesn't sleep and that right there
starts the pattern
to where she won't sleep for about a
week and then
sometimes she'll make it to two weeks
with no sleep and so what happens is she
just starts
her anxiety starts building up and
building up and building up because i'm
sure
as you know you know sleep kind of
resets the mind and calms everything
down
so with her anxiety going through the
roof um the way
that it was explained to me is that when
she doesn't sleep for that long a period
of time
all the events that have ever happened
in her life are happening at once
and so she can't tell the difference
between what happened 10 years ago and
what's happening today
because she's gone so long without sleep
they're all happening to her at the same
time
and so she ends up um calling the police
selling telling them that she was
attacked or that something like that
happened
and usually this is usually every time
it's at this event
at this stage i'm usually at home she's
gone out somewhere
so during this entire process she's home
maybe for
10 hours and it's hard to get her to
stay home because she doesn't want to
sit still
because her anxiety is just up up up up
and she can't get it down
does she does she use drugs too
no she doesn't use drugs um she says she
smoked pot like once when she was like
17 but no she doesn't do any sort of
drugs or anything like that
so does she does she not take her meds
will she not take her
any medications so i still
a couple of times well the first time
when they were telling me what was going
on i was kind of getting filled in on it
they told me it was postpartum
depression so i didn't worry about her
taking men okay
um the second time she was kind of
taking mets for a little bit
and using it more as a stop gap same
thing with the third time the fourth
time
um then she she realized that things
were going on she got back on track
rather quickly and then this last time
she's been getting shots
every month so she doesn't have to take
meds every day
um and she still fell off the wagon okay
so i want to do a couple of things here
okay
number one i can hear in your voice a
frustrated exhausted don't know what to
do
husband and dad okay
but i can also hear in your voice where
this has turned from frustration
to now this is a lady who's ruining your
life
and i want you to find a couple of folks
in your life that will hold you
accountable to
always keeping compassion in the front
and center of your mind and heart
okay okay it is
true bipolar if that's really what this
is
um is just devastating
but it can start to feel like someone's
attacking you
and nobody who is truly struggling from
this wants to
be there okay and the more
you can keep yourself from attacking
back
the better now i'm going to walk you
through the next things
step two here is you have a
personal um ethical moral
spiritual any other descriptive word you
want to say
you've got a you've got an obligation to
take care of your children and make sure
they're safe
and it doesn't sound like they're in a
safe situation right now
um with the sporadicness mom
disappearing for
days on end weeks on end suddenly their
kids are getting ripped out of their
home to go somewhere else while dad's
being investigated for
totally baseless claims that's going to
wreak havoc
on their ability to connect it's going
to be wreak havoc on their stability
and it's going to put you in a defensive
posture mom's totally absent
i'm just telling you right now your kids
are going to start a
lifetime of searching for connection in
all sorts of different ways
okay so i want you to consciously start
thinking about how i can protect my kids
the third thing is this i do believe
that
if this is relatively new if you've
known and i relatively knew by a couple
of years
if when y'all are dating there were no
signs of bipolar if when y'all were
y'all been together for a long time
there's no signs of bip you know y'all
been together for a while and then she
has a challenging
first birth of your son and then this
comes out afterwards
i i don't know for sure if that's what
this is is what i'm telling you
i think it is wise if she will and she
might not
that you spend the money you spend the
time in the investment to go
meet with a psychiatrist who knows what
they're doing who will spend
not 30 minutes with y'all but who will
spend an extended amount of time with
you guys
to walk through the history of this
thing and will give you
and your family a plan for moving
forward that's probably going to involve
a social worker who works directly with
this psychiatrist and i've seen this
work out in
a good tandem there um
and but it's going to be a team effort
moving forward
and then she's going to have to commit
to staying on the plan
um and if she doesn't she's just going
to wreak havoc in the life of those kids
and it's as you know it's very hard to
stay tethered in
and married to this sporadic-ness i also
get your till death do his part
until death do his part for sickness and
health for richer and for poor
and i get that too and so one thing you
will never hear from me
ever ever ever you will never hear from
me recommending divorce
telling someone you got to get out of
here unless it's a very specific
specific sort of abuse situation so i'm
not going to make that call for you
brother
i'm going to tell you you gotta gotta
take care of those kids put them number
one and keep them safe
number two if you all haven't sat down
and fully got a plan
if these shots she's taken or just from
another pcp that you went in and met
with
so be it if she's doing extended
hospitalizations my guess is she's got a
social worker and a psychiatrist that
she works with her
but you all need to go in together and
make a forever plan
that she's going to stay on if it's
truly bipolar one of the biggest
challenges bipolar is
medication can work wonders and then
people feel really good and they quit
taking
their medication and so i would i would
challenge you all to get on a plan and
then
have her commit to staying on it and
then you'll begin to work on behaviors
down the road but y'all are that's way
down the road for you guys
right now we're talking about
stabilization um i want you to go get a
second opinion from a different doctor
from a different psychiatrist who will
work directly with you guys and your
family
um and again i want to go back to the
first thing i told you man this sucks
i wish there was an easy fix on this one
i wish there was a
oh yeah i just do this in this and this
is all gonna that's not how bipolar
works that's not how devastating mental
illness works
that's not how being a parent with
someone that you love who's suddenly
changed and now your kids are not safe
now you're not safe that's not how this
works
and so christopher there's not an easy
fix on this one
but it's going to be a day by day
process start with the doctor start with
taking care of your kids
one more thing i'm going to put out
there and i'm i'm
thinking through this as i'm talking is
i want you to sit down with your parents
if her parents are in the picture sit
down with her parents
and i want you all to come up with a
game plan together
if she has a couple of friends in her
life that are stable whether that's some
church friends whether that
is a sister or a cousin that she trusts
it may be a moment for an intervention
where everybody sits down and says hey
we all have agreed that this is going to
be the plan here
one to take care of these children two
to take care of your safety
and three to do what we can to preserve
this marriage
and um getting as many people who love
her
and respect her and want her to see her
be successful and that
she trusts in some little sliver to
speak into her heart and mind
that'll help a lot that'll really help a
lot
but at the end of the day you can only
control you and you can only control
your thoughts and your actions so
default to compassion as hard as that is
brother i know that's hard when somebody
calls the cops on you and somebody out
of their own delusion somebody out of
their own sickness
gets your kids taken away for a few days
i get the rage part of that i get the
attack part of that
and you're gonna have to do some hard
spiritual searching to not default to
that
because that's just going to poison your
house and at the end of the day it's
going to poison your kids man
do the best you can to default to
compassion get somebody in your life you
can be vulnerable with
and then two you got to protect those
kids you got to protect those kids and
you got to have those hard
get well conversations with your wife
we'll be thinking about you
hey man after you have this conversation
with her after you get together with a
doctor and a social worker team
y'all can kind of come up with a plan
after you do an intervention with your
family i want you to call me back
christopher i want to hear how this goes
and um hear if she gets on the road
to healing or not or have her call me
man i'd love to talk to her directly i'd
love to talk to her directly
but thank you so much for the call and
thank everybody for calling in today
again make a plan february is not going
to surprise anybody
january's not going to surprise anybody
it's going to be cold it's going to be
dreary it's going to be dark and we're
going to feel
more lonely we're going to feel more
isolated we're going to feel more uneasy
and if you're like me i'm not expecting
the election to just be a smooth
walk in the park either so start now
coming up with plans and ideas for being
safe
check the show notes again for the five
things i've listed and let's end today
as we end all
shows i've been thinking about the
greatest song of all time and i stumbled
into it
i thought i had it in the previous 15 20
shows i was wrong
i was wrong the greatest song ever
written was written in 1967
it was released on his classic
axis bold as love record
the godfather of the guitar jimi hendrix
known for his weedily deedly dearly dees
but here he's known for his words as he
writes in his
classic little wing
while she's walking through the clouds
with a circus mind that's running around
butterflies and zebras and moonbeams
and fairy tales that's all she ever
thinks about
riding with the wind and when i'm sad
she comes to me with a thousand smiles
she gives to me free
it's all right she said it's all right
take anything you want from me
anything anything fly on little wing
jimmy fly on little wing this is the dr
john dalone's show